[Music]
hello friends
my name is eric zee and i am the chef
owner of 886 taiwanese restaurant in the
east village of manhattan
today i'm going to show you what i eat
in a day
for breakfast i like to eat something
that is healthy nutritious now let's see
what we can use
for our
avocado toast cabbage
some a choi
some leftover take out
eggs
this is the egg that we're gonna need i
apologize for the messiness yeah i was
gonna grab the avocado in the milk bread
you gotta make the
avocado mash it's like a fake guacamole
some nice
milk bread
i'm always thinking about
that far far away day when we're able to
reopen and i've taken a lot of time to
cook at home to kind of play around with
different ingredients
things that i
never really thought of doing for the
restaurant we actually tried selling
this uh avocado
xiaobi shopping is a traditional
chinese pastry it was delicious but not
a lot of people ordered it
save
the non-broken one
for the wife
and that'll be for me
cheers
[Music]
this is why i cook
it's so
good and my mood is brightened
i woke up when i was taking a shower i
didn't know how to tackle my day i don't
know if we're gonna open for delivery i
don't know
what the hell we gonna do
i was so lost when i woke up and now
life is good
for lunch my wife is working from home
as a teacher i have to
really really quickly crank out
something that's super simple and
delicious we're going to make a
healthier version of an instant noodle
the difference between these noodles and
instant noodles is that they're actually
a they're not instant because they're
actually raw noodles
air dried think about dried pasta it's
the same thing you know what else we're
gonna make i think we're just gonna
make a quick stir fry out of pea shoots
my noodles
packet says six minutes what the corn
will do is kind of
create little bites of sweetness
to balance the
spiciness of the noodles
it's hot
it's good enough
this is kind of a new trend in asia i
feel in taiwan every celebrity has their
own brand of these dried noodles it's a
nice healthy alternative to
instant noodles
so sexy
and so i've been cooking professionally
for five years now and if the food looks
beautiful it's going to taste better so
if you have a dish that's like solid b
or b plus the plating and the visuals
the colors could elevate that to an a
minus
noodle
noodle
and this is a bit of a pea shoot and a
tofu skin that just stir-fried it all
right let's
try out this noodle
well the corn really compliments it
quick lunch and then uh
the woman off camera here is gotta get
back to work
[Music]
all right
so it's about 4 30 in the afternoon i
just got back from a bunch of errands
and looking for a light snack snackity
snack
all right
chop it up
rough
still want to keep it
kind of kind of cute
got some vanilla ice cream
from mcconnell's
yeah
yeah
sorry you have to watch this
let's take this guy
see if this works out here
[Music]
garnished with a little cilantro
cilantro is actually very commonly used
in dessert
for taiwanese cuisine here's my snack
it's funny how sweet things kind of
brighten your mood
i was only gonna have like two bites and
i was gonna share with my wife but
tough
luck
for dinner dinner is usually what i kind
of plan my days around it's where i can
show
my love for my wife and tonight
we have a 24-hour sous-vide short room
that i'm super super excited about
so what i did was i took a whole plate
of short ribs i deboned it
and then i made a marinade out of soy
sauce sichuan pepper star nice
trying to mimic that
really classic chinese braised beef
flavor and with the short rib
sous-viding in the marinade it'll soak
up all the flavors in the seasoning i'm
able to just leave it in the water bath
for 24 hours
and it will have a melt in your mouth
delicious delicious texture so it's been
24 hours let's see
made a mess
you can still see how tender it is oh
baby
baby baby toast some of us right
there we go
look at this guy
do you not want to marry this beef all
right and it is smoking hot
[Music]
so inspiration behind this dish is those
fancy wagyu katsusandos that you see
everywhere on the internet nowadays but
we're substituting different flavors
into a very familiar dish so it looks
like something but it tastes like
something else that's a technique i
really like and i try a lot to play
around with
also made some brussels sprouts
and a little
seafood with tofu
pretty excited for this guy
[Music]
i'm gonna try to put this on the menu i
know it's gonna be difficult because one
huge plate of shortbread
pretty much only yielded this portion
you know what i'm gonna i'm gonna stop
filming because i'm so excited to eat
dinner
thank you for watching
what i eat in a day
[Music]
[Music]